Meet Jack.
Tracking all of work and life's information has turned Jack into a note monster.
Now meet Jack's friend, Jill.
Jill is an awesomeness machine.
Jill always seems to remember the slightest bit of data.
Information doesn't control Jill.
Jill controls information.
Jill has so much extra time on her hands that she can nurture her secret love:...
...collecting farm animals in origami.
What's Jill's secret?
Evernote: the superhuman maker.
If only everyone could use Evernote.
Idea, Jill?
Evernote grabs your information from anywhere and transports it to the magical cloud of elephants.
Whether text note, snapshot, web clip or audio,...
...Evernote's tireless elephants automatically categorize and index your information,...
...preparing it all for instant retrieval whenever and wherever you need it.
Evernote transforms the common note monster into a superhuman.
Idea, Jack?
And so ends our story of Jack and Jill.
Another happy ending, another note monster vanquished.
All thanks to Evernote.
Evernote.
Remember everything.